[Musique]
plusieurs refusent toujours de croire
qu'on traverse en ce moment une
situation de crise pandémique
parmi la multitude d'arguments mis de
l'avant et à la baisse marquée de
l'achalandage dans les salles d'urgence
de nos hôpitaux
un point chaud l'hôpital l'individu qui
filme et commentent la scène laisse
entendre que la salle d'urgence green de
l'hôpital lasalle à montréal mais
prouverait que la crise de la coved 19
est exagérée par les autorités et d'y
assurer médias le même procédé a été
récupéré un peu partout dans le monde
des centaines de vidéos regroupés sous
le mot clic fumeur aspire aux oufs il
met vos hôpitaux en france aux états
unis au brésil toujours la même recette
du couloir vide
le personnel à mes pieds pour des eaux
en syrie toutes ces personnes ont raison
à propos d'un seul élément les salles
d'urgence un peu partout dans le monde
sont nettement moins achalandées ça
c'est vrai dans la région de montréal
les taux d'occupation des urgences
avoisine le 60% soit bien loin du 100 %
ou du 110 % habituels selon le docteur
gilbert boucher qu'il préside
l'association des spécialistes en
médecine d'urgence du québec
cette baisse est simplement due aux
politiques mises en place pour préparer
le système hospitalier affronter la
crise de la coved 19 et parce que la
population respecte les consignes de la
distanciation sociale selon le docteur
boucher on a donc demandé au centre
hospitalier de libérer le maximum de
ressources pour accueillir d'éventuelles
vagues de patients atteints de la kobe
19 qui nécessitent on le sait souvent
malheureusement des soins aigus et on
demande aussi parfois à des patients
potentiellement atteindre la kobe 19 mai
qui ne présentent pas de symptômes
graves de retourner à la maison et de
revenir seulement si les symptômes
s'aggravent
le confinement fait aussi en sorte qu'on
enregistre une baisse des visites à
l'urgence pour des crises cardiaques par
exemple parce que le changement de mode
de vie des gens semble se refléter dans
le fait qu'il ya moins de pathologies à
traiter d'urgence
bref ce que les autorités cherchent à
éviter à tout prix avec et ses mesures
exceptionnelles
ce sont les scènes de chaos des hôpitaux
new yorkais
encore du nord de l'italie est prise
pour approfondir cette analyse je vous
suggère la lecture de l'article de mon
collègue jeff yates à ce sujet et si
vous doutez d'une information en
particulier avant de la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
écrivez-nous aux courriels des
décrypteurs salut
[Musique]